after magnus played the most c6  what was  the time spent well i was trying to  calculate if there are like any  practical chances and uh  perhaps there is no big difference there  do  they calculate uh  sitting at the boards or in the room uh  but yeah the best i i could produce was  okay this  uh i don't know rook b6 ic5 idea but  it's it's it's far from any  anything realistic of course after you  played c5 how long did it take to occur  to you that c6 was possible um until it  was played okay i was quite happy but uh  somehow for 25 vb5 is mandatory but  uh i mean yeah okay so that's  also the problem that c6 idea never  works or while my phone is on c4  uh so you have just  some insanely bad luck  so just to clarify so you didn't notice  c6 until magnus played it uh indeed  i see uh your feelings now about the  match  situation given five games together uh  it's worse than i expected